guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel today I have a tick tock
compilation reaction and I am with
friends that are going to be reacting to
hi I'm Pearl's friend
hello I'm an extra guy here my name is
King riches so we're going to be
reacting to some tick tocks that I've
seen this week
in pilation
roll the footage blessing
[Laughter]
I lay down the lodge she's not agreeable
anymore
okay okay
oh
you just wants to see his dad
hey let him see his dad
The Shape of My Heart
oh
thought to make me cry
what do you guys think about when
mothers don't let their kids see their
fathers selfish I think I think those
women that do that are scumbags to be
honest it hurts the child it
manipulators as well and they're abusing
their position of power in the situation
I think that they should go to jail I
think that a woman who does not let the
dad see their kids should face jail time
I think that's how serious they should
take it because you're putting your kid
at every statistical disadvantage you
possibly could by not letting them see
their father yeah in the um the
psychological development as well by not
having their father around and and it's
gonna cause trauma down the line and I
feel like the one thing they forget is
that the kids grow up eventually you can
tell them that he was a deadbeat you can
tell them all these stories but one day
they'll grow up and they'll find out
they'll ask their dad for his side of
the story I mean how many kids does that
happen to you saw it happen to Kanye I
have a really good friend who growing up
so her parents got divorced really young
and growing up her mom told her that her
dad cheated
um on Mom and then you know they refuse
to talk to the father for years and come
to find out it was the other way around
she cheated she cheated and they didn't
have a relationship with their father
for years because of a lie and honestly
I think it's selfish of women to tell
the kids about their problems like great
like if you're not their business why
did the kids know they should not know
if the dad cheated I agree 100 and also
why do you want to put your biased view
into your kids brains because it's their
dad and and they don't talk about why he
cheated like one of four marriages are
sexless sexless that means he hasn't had
sex in months like that that's cruel to
do to a man that's cruel to anybody
that's a joke I wish a woman would try
to do that to me that oh yeah I'm
married to you now nah you're not
getting no more books bro I'm gonna get
books bro 100 but I'm not ugly dude bro
like you know what I'm saying but anyway
that's beside the point I just feel a
lot of times in these situations when
the mom is just trying to manipulate
brainwash the children against the dad
it's just like she's got lies you know
what I mean so yeah it's boom it's me
and the kids again me and my kids
against the dad like um it's spiteful
because it's like hurting there it's her
trying to get back at the husband for he
hurt her now I'm gonna hurt you even
worse with your children and the kids
grow up and they find out kids aren't
stupid no no kids are much more
intelligent than anyone gives them
credit for they've noticed everything
and they grow up and they'll figure out
what you did because you can't run from
yourself and if you're the type of
person that is taking like you're the
kids away from the dad if you're that
type of person there's other issues with
your personality too and they're gonna
see it the only time that I personally
feel like I can understand or I agree
with it is if it's like more of a
abusive situation like if the father has
put the kids in situations that are
harmful that can't be trusted like let's
say that he does drugs and when he's had
the kids brought them around other
people doing drugs or drugs in general
or if he has hit the children I wouldn't
let my kids around them okay do you know
what I found out that's actually messed
up so in a court I don't know the exact
terminology but I just found this out
the other day in divorce court a woman
can claim abuse and not actually and
basically if she convinces the jury in
divorce court that she was abused even
though like it didn't have a separate
court for itself like she basically can
lie and say she was abused and if they
think she may have been like they will
still award the kids to the mother so
there's like incentive for her to lie
that the husband abused her which in
turn and her women are lying about it
exactly and the other thing is that one
of my followers brought up this point
because I had that point and he said why
can't they do it's called it's like a
visitation where there's someone else a
third party has to be there so even if
he's like an abusive Dad it's kind of
like if a guy's in prison like they can
still see the dad and know who the dad
is but there's always a third party to
like protect them yeah and I was like
that's actually a good point why can
they not see the dad if he's got issues
or whatever I still think it's important
for them to know who their dad is and if
they get to a certain age and they say I
don't want to deal with him that's fine
exactly but I didn't realize that they
can literally accuse a guy of abuse and
not have to prove it when we first
started like talking about this kind of
stuff back when your Channel first
started and you'd bring it up I would be
like so like taken aback when you'd say
how the court system is more in favor of
a woman but it's really true I mean
imagine women get custody 90 of the time
imagine if that was flipped and women
only got custody 10 of the time they
would say they would say oh my God like
women are being discriminated against
they can't even see their kids but like
for the vice versa nobody bats an eye
and it's just it's just kind of crazy
because like men don't even really
complain about this stuff yeah something
to think about it's eye-opening isn't it
I just think it's funny in this
particular Tick Tock that um The Charles
obviously went into see his dad and like
the mom is being an obstacle to that the
child is not gonna forget that memory
he's not gonna forget that all you
obstructed me from seeing my parent like
he's gonna grow up to resent the mom so
really what that woman was doing in The
Tick Tock is really silly you're not
gonna gain an ally doing that you're
just actually creating another enemy in
your own home I will say that we saw saw
like a small clip we don't know what
happened before after maybe the
situation could have been literally like
I don't know he didn't want to he wants
to see his dad today even though he's
going to see his dad tomorrow and he's
like throwing a fit we don't really know
but from what you do see it's like
heartbreaking the one thing you found
with women is a deception that a man
can't attain there is a level of Spite
and deception that goes along with women
and abusing one woman she was getting
her her child and she was getting the
feet of the child and she was putting
them up a vagina
um sort of reenacting at Birth of the
child yeah you know at a time one uh
when one was putting sugary stuff
whatever on her vagina and getting her
little baby because her babies they've
got a natural ability to suckle yeah and
so instead of breastfeeding baby she was
putting on a clitoris and a baby she was
doing that
um one guy was in a care home and he
said don't you know that the men were
abusing him he said but the women were
the worst and he said there was loads of
us young boys from 6 to 13 and every day
he would have to go to the school hall
we all had to strip off naked it so
you're getting boys prepubescent and
pubescent but all have to line up and
the head Mistress of the school would
sit there and make all the girls of this
residential school watch they were all
clothed while um she took them one by
one she came them and fidded with their
genitals and then off they went to get
changed and then get ready for their
evening meal every night that went on
you know it's crazy I know two people
that lost their virginity to a
babysitter there were guys that whole
title is wild to me like I didn't know
that was going on out there like that
like obviously men and women both can be
sick and do terrible things but to that
extent of what he described that's mad
it made me feel better that's it
together think about think about
Epstein's Island who was on the front
lines Epstein was the top guy right and
that was messed up but who was the one
marketing it and actually getting the
girls to do it it was other girls and
it's like sometimes I feel like there's
a lot more female abuse than people
really know because I don't think men
are the first to come forward about it
especially if they were like teenagers
or something it comes back to this whole
thing of you know man up in it you know
you're a man just take it and even
there's some people out there who are
completely wrong that may say well as a
boy you should be okay with certain
things happening to you do you get what
I'm saying or like you should be proud
like you're happy yeah like happier than
having like I have a friend of mine he
lost his virginity to his cousin who's
12 and his cousin was older she was in
her 20s and when he went to tell his
friends his friends were like dabbing
him up and he was like I don't want this
and then he didn't tell anyone when he
takes 12 12. so gross and it takes a
psychological effect that's gonna be
serious trauma that he's gonna carry on
especially for the fact that he's been
taught that oh you should see that's a
cool thing so now his perception of sex
will be walked as well again he ended up
falling into kind of a sex addiction he
was super hypersexual and would be
sleeping with anything and was
constantly having sex now that he's
older he's has extremely low sex drive
because it's like traumatizing for him
to have sex and I bet that girl's still
out there crazy thing she still sees her
at holidays so nasty it's crazy this is
unbelievable part of the story Canada's
Pediatric Society says it's okay to
basically eliminate children you know as
long as they show signs that they are
mature let me repeat that Canada's
Pediatric Society under these made laws
oh my God I forgot I put this in the
compilation this is so messed up this is
deeply says hey if the child is mature
enough like they're not an adult yet not
18 but if they're showing signs of
maturity then they can we're going to
refer to them as mature Miners and they
can make a determination to kill to be
assisted suicide and taken care of
basically if they can decide their own
gender they can no but this is the same
yeah you make a good point this is the
same thing is that children should be
able to change their bodies make these
decisions make adult decisions as minors
oh you're 12 and you're depressed well
here you go we don't even need to check
with the parents you're immature you're
a mature Miner you're 12. you seem like
you're mature do you want a doctor's
note to go and you know take care of
that thing called life like that's what
they're talking about here we have the
red and blue pill we have the hormone
blocker or the life taker which one do
you want red yeah yeah it's continuing
to live how you are right now is not an
option unbelievable mature miners
last for us are sacred when I imagine my
final days I see bubbles
[Music]
I see the ocean
as I seek help to end my life there is
still so much Beauty you just have to be
brave enough to see it
[Music]
yeah so she's no longer with us how
[__] up is that wow that is wild it's
assisted suicide in Canada and like kids
can sign up for it yeah that is I don't
agree with any of that doesn't matter
that's just off and how many people do
you know that had a [__] up like
teenager they might make a decision when
they're like 13 14 where it's like maybe
they wanted life was hard then but life
gets better oh 100 I'm thinking about
back when I was really struggling that
would have been something that I would
have looked at but like you know what
I'm saying I wouldn't be here now yeah
like when you're young you can't see
into the future when you're going
through things at a young age you don't
see past it but there is life past it
and they're marketing that that is crazy
like the suicidal people that's the most
vulnerable them and children are the
most vulnerable part of the population
and they're like trying to profit off of
that and take advantage of them that's
crazy and I uh disgusting the scariest
like I just want to piggyback of what
Gabby was saying this like I remember I
had a time when I was extremely low
extreme depression I didn't see any kind
of on the tunnel like I didn't know
where my my life was going and at those
times sometimes I thought like what's
the point what is the point and that's
scary that they would Market that to
Young mature miners like that's scary
like again it's just like what you said
you don't know that you can't see the
future when you're in those dark pits
you can't see that okay five years time
I'm gonna be a different person 10 years
time I'm gonna be flying bro that's ad
complete do not agree with that I think
that's quite evil in my opinion it is as
a single woman I'm operating in my
masculine energy I pay my own bills I
pay to get my nails done I get my hair
done hold on man hold on bro
I don't think you're qualified to be
talking about anything just by me
looking at this I'm not gonna go too
deep but to look at what I'm looking at
I just don't think certain people
shouldn't be talking certain people need
to work on other things self-development
so she's in her masculine energy because
she pays for herself like shouldn't she
just do that as an adult you're just an
adult
you pay your phone bill well done on you
pay for the lights and electricity well
done I mean how expensive are your bills
they don't have to be that expensive
unless you make them that way you can
eat rice and chicken
yeah it's cheap too I think they're good
friends I do everything on my own so I'm
fully operating in my masculine energy
but in what I'm with a man when I'm with
my man I am submissive feminine loyal
dubbing every other man who comes my way
because my man is now stepping in his
masculine role to take care of me to get
my nails done to pay my bills to take
care of me as a single woman I have the
right to be a baddie to date multiple
people to have a roster of men who are
whining and dining me until one wants to
be serious and be exclusive with me and
put a ring on this finger and be with me
for forever that is the difference
between single Gabby and in a
relationship
don't bring my name into this don't
bring me up I don't know you my name is
Gabby what do you guys think rosters I'd
like to see this roster of guys
I think she's true
I just think it's stupid like men look
for loyalty and man look go for good
looks bro I know okay I know everyone
has that okay but a lot of people don't
I'm talking about the roster oh well I'm
deciding I know I know it started it
starts with looks Michael yeah but some
people on Tick Tock making these tick
tocks don't have good looks and they
come out talking rubbish look at there's
always a sound there will always there
will always be a Sim I don't care if
she's 75. they're out there and
overweight they're waiting they're weird
there's always always a Sim I just feel
like men look for loyalty and I don't
think having a roster is good for you I
feel like it's gonna make it harder to
attach personally I can't even pay
attention to that many people I think
I'm like I know I'd be trying to get you
to respond to me sometimes
I don't
I just think if a girl just throws a box
with too many men she's gonna get burnt
out and once she's burnt out she's done
in it she won't be able to sit down with
one guy happily that's what I think and
I've seen it happen like so all you
women that think oh yeah I'm winning
I've got all these guys yeah you
smashing that one sucking off the other
one you're just messing yourself up you
won't be happy in the end what do you
think actually I have a random question
I just thought I saw this on the show
the other day what do you think all
right if a girl cheats and she cheats on
you and she hooks up has sex with
another guy or she blows another guy
what's worse I actually thought about
that uh what's worse
for sure that's so personal yeah you
could just have sex with someone and
just lay there and it's not personal but
sucking a dick sorry
both is just horrible yeah
okay okay you gotta pick one [__] I
have to take them she has to get [__]
that's worse
you know what that's not as bad because
the sucking she put him in her mouth
that's a d That's a deeper one if it's
the [__] one yeah he could put a
condom so technically the Skin's not
perfect
please don't touch him and he probably
nutted down her throat too she's yeah oh
yeah yeah
second question
wait wait if he if he cheats what's
worse would you rather a guy cheat on
you through a [__] or sex like what's
worse none of the above because if he
cheats on me he's not making it out okay
okay Gabby we gotta pick one this is
foreign
you're married with three kids okay so
you gotta work it out you gotta work it
out because you love your kids you want
your family first fact so you find out
he cheated okay now you get to find out
one of two things let's say one one way
he cheated he had sex with another girl
the other way he cheated he got a
[__] from another girl what one would
you rather him have done this is tricky
because I'm gonna say this and one day
my husband's gonna be like well you said
you would rather
just answer the question
sex cause condom actually no [__]
[__] I would say I would rather him
get the [__] yeah because it's like
one I feel like she's probably more of a
hoe for sure but yeah if she's like I
just in my head it's like a guy will let
anyone and I know men release a hormone
when they have sex that makes them like
territorial over that woman so I'm like
you know what I don't know if it's equal
for [__] well to be fair sometimes
Dick's just fall into people's mouths so
but I think obviously I don't I don't
know what women think but I would
imagine that if the man gets hit from
another chick it's not that deep it's
not as deep as like he wrapped up in the
girl sweating like penetrating could
still be fully clothed and he could be
fully clothed and it could just be in
the Buckle like I'm saying like
sometimes penises just fall in girl's
mouths
304's mouth there is an example
what this looks like look I made 1250
this is the last the most recent
paycheck I got and this is because of
Corona and okay Child Support I'm
getting screwed so hard so 12.50 that's
what I made that's what I got that's my
check there's my child support Focus
there's my child support right there
that's what I get man how many of you
parents out there are giving your
children more money than you can afford
for yourself like this is ridiculous I'm
getting Strokes I can't believe this I'm
a bottom bum right now I'm not the bum
that's on the side of the street begging
for money look looking for Ducky's son
man living for free and off other people
and using government helping and such
like that man I'm not doing any of that
and I'm working my ass off to be
homeless and I can't even get government
help because I make too much money at
the end of the year like I make too much
money to get help and this is what I'm
left with that's two weeks that's two
weeks look at the month here's the money
here's the month here is the month
that's the next one here's the month
11.95 I get 333 so what's that 680
dollars six hundred and ninety dollars
roughly 680 that's what I made for the
whole month that's my monthly income
that I get to take home with me that's
why I'm homeless child support is why
I'm homeless child support is the
biggest scam on the face of the planet
let's see here's one maybe look at that
one that's what I made one time that's
back in September 750 man 260 144 child
support man you think I'm bullshitting
this child support look this is one
this is one right here where I paid the
entire amount of Child Support today oh
this is the entire amount of Child
Support I know I made fifteen hundred
dollars I take home 482 that's my full
amount of child support that I have to
pay every month [__] is ridiculous man
please someone tell me how to live how
the [__] do you do this how do you do
this life is this is not something's
wrong here man because I'm not addicted
to drugs and I'm not lazy I work my butt
off for this you know what I'm saying
and I just get screwed I just don't know
what to do man I'm done with this 20.
how crazy is that the man is homeless
she has a full paying job and he's
homeless because he has on child support
and don't have kids I'm sorry you we
always talk about or you guys always
talk about accountability then don't nut
in women like if you can't afford
children then stop nutting in girls and
having babies with people you can't
trust so I have a question do you think
that if a girl says she's on birth
control and she's not that she should be
prosecuted yes abroad because a lot of
times like the girls will say that
they're on something and while maybe
like he shouldn't trust it it's like if
you're dating someone you think you can
trust them no I hear you on that but you
know and and it's like where's the
accountability why does the woman get
bailed out of her bad choice like she's
not saying she gets bailed out but he
doesn't get bailed out either so
obviously he doesn't have the kids with
him so you're just gonna have a woman
take care of children and you're not
gonna pay but remember Gabby they get
custody 90 of the time so men aren't
really given a choice so it's basically
like if they don't get the kid 90 of the
time the woman gets custody I think it
might be 80 now but it's still the odds
aren't good right I feel bad for the guy
so then he's forced to he doesn't get
primary custody of the kids and now he
has so much child support that he's
going homeless and a lot of times in the
court system this is something I learned
they're incentivized to overestimate the
cost of what it costs to raise a kid
because the court system makes money off
of their child support payments so they
say that it costs more to raise a child
than it does and that's why you see a
lot of women will say they're single
mothers and like they can't afford their
kids but they have their nails done
their hair done they're like full face
the makeup and it's like a lot of times
the child support they don't even know
if it's going towards the kids so a man
the only choice he had was nut or not
nut or the woman had the choice of the
abortion she had the choice to put them
on child support or not put him on child
support she had the choice to marry him
or not like we have all these choices
the man if they get a girl pregnant
they're just screwed yeah it's unfair
but at the same time I'm not going to
sit here and listen to someone a grown
man complain who you made your bed now
you have to lie in it yeah just might
not no no I'm not saying man up that is
basically what you're saying no I'm
saying it is what you're saying you said
everything he said yeah yeah yeah but
I'm not gonna listen to a grown man
that's basically complain about paying
for his children but it's like seven
eight hundred a month we don't know how
many kids he has two and you could see
it on there he has two children two kids
did you think he had like 18 kids or
something what's going on no I'm just
saying I think it's ridiculous if the
law or the court or whoever was in
charge actually was able to detail what
the money was going to in terms of their
children then it would make sense but
it's really they're just calculating a
percentage of the man's wage and giving
it to the woman I feel like in these
kind of cases a woman needs to justify
why she needs that money because
especially if the kid is a very small
child it's not like the child is going
Here There and Everywhere but I think a
lot of times the money's just been
handed over and the woman's just doing
whatever and then living a movie I just
don't think you're entitled to child
support from a man I feel like we're in
control of who we have sex with and if
you make a poor decision why do you
deserve to be paid for it I didn't get
pregnant can I get paid for that like I
did the right thing and I don't get
anybody why do you get money for doing
the wrong thing that's like a gotcha
I'll be real with you because I come
from a single parent household and my
dad didn't do anything I do think as a
parent you are obligated to look after
your children that is your
responsibility that's your duty but I
don't think the risk of going to prison
should be a part of it and I think as I
said that it should be justified the
amount that is allocated needs to be
justified receipts need to be collected
that will negate any kind of nonsense
but I do think as a man it's difficult
because a woman does have all the power
but if a child comes into this world
unless you're just gonna completely
remove rights to that child which should
be allowed as well if you just don't
want to have no connection then boom you
have no rights over that child and then
no response I think you can sign away
your rights but the problem is like
there's no way like then you have no
legal rights as a parent so my issue is
that I just don't think you should be
entitled to pay child support I feel
like it should be 50 50 custody no child
support that's what I think that should
always be the starting point 50 50 no
child support yeah that makes sense 50
50 yeah and even if outside of abuse
that's like that's where it started my
opinion I agree I agree as well not them
laughing at the thought of PLO dating
someone outside their wealth Circle
the right kind of guy like an accountant
or something or a plumber
aren't you the comedian
I like how the grandma is like trying to
give her real dating advice like maybe
the athletes aren't working out Chloe
and they're like ah no no we can't give
up the athletes not the laugh that Kris
Jenner had though she's like and that's
why I see things like that I know you
don't find that funny I didn't really
find that funny you probably saw my face
was not changed this is why I don't have
no sympathy when women mess their lives
up they go for these guys I want an
athlete I want an NBA player oh I could
never date a plumber and in their life
turns to
I have no King sympathy for you ever and
I think a lot of guys need to have that
same mentality have no King sympathy for
you women who think you're better than
the plumber whatever because you make x
amount of money so that makes you better
no it doesn't actually and a lot of
these women who are boss [__] or
whatever A lot of them are single a lot
of them are baby mamas just like the
women in the low income projects are all
in the hood you're just a baby mama with
some money that's true they've had every
opportunity you possibly could have for
love and they're in the right circles to
find a guy that would yeah you have no
reason to fail bro I don't have no
sympathy like [__] you that's what I
figured it I can't think of one time a
man's complimented me where it's not
like oh you're really funny and I love
that I'll eat that update night yeah but
um I'm not getting compliments from my
look so never everything I feel like you
do in your comments now people are
really nice to you yeah they're lovely
women that's hard because like I never
got a combo from like a man in person
like you like smoking hot people get
those no I mean sometimes my guy friends
will compliment me like that they're
like oh gee you look so great and that
makes me feel nice yeah our guy friends
always tell us we look great yeah that's
nice yeah yeah but it's like how do they
cap come on that makes you feel so happy
you know damn well a guy has called you
hot stop cat because you're the
prettiest one in the stop it she's like
constantly seeking out like male
validation yeah that's like what makes
if a man tells me that I look good then
all of a sudden I am so high and I look
so good but it shouldn't be coming from
men honestly it shouldn't even be coming
from women it should be coming from like
yourself yeah whatever we feel good oh
don't you feel that I'm sorry no I don't
work like that it's not a real world but
it's like they don't want male
validation but they do that's the crazy
thing like the compliment doesn't even
count yeah and like they only care if
the men say it you can hear it when
they're talking but they don't dress for
male validation uh oh I don't put makeup
on for guys I don't put on sexy clothes
for guys I don't do my hair for guys oh
for guys bro because the guys that you
like ain't giving you the validation now
is oh I just did it for myself and why
are they capping to the girl stop I like
her I like her too but you know damn
well why do you like her why because
she's a woman that's why she's funny and
entertaining if you notice in the
previous clip with the Kardashians when
there was laughing at the plumber
beautiful ladies here were laughing and
I had a straight face that when it came
to that girl complaining oh guys don't
holler at me or no them two had straight
faces and I was laughing
yeah I thought I was laughing at bold
but maybe I wasn't I don't know I just
thought it was crazy the Kardashians
were looking at the
because they live in a different world
and everyone else in the universe I
would date a plumber hit me up they made
some money you know six figures and they
can fix things yeah look I'm with it
your toilet will never bust down
but that's the thing why are they cap it
pretty girls they always do this they're
like you know why she's not getting
approached yeah you know why people
she's like well I feel like people do do
it in your comment section people no one
even calls me pretty shut up you know
damn well that you have been called hot
they're just trying to abuse the ego man
[Music]
and compilation not compilation I like
the way she says it yeah that's the new
way
of Pearl's World Pearl's World her rules
I don't know I just every time I see one
on Tech talk I like heart it and I'll
come back oh The Tick Tock you're not
banned on yeah I follow my Tick Tock
just poorly things dot five I just hit
100K on it
any final thoughts you guys have I still
think that child support he should be
paying it that's it okay what about you
I just think we got to all the plumbers
out here man don't listen to dummies on
the internet trying to make you feel bad
about you know promo you fix a lot of
things if it wasn't for plumbers ask
women how do we get clean water exactly
it just appears where there's good where
the clean water come from they have no
answer there you go okay guys like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time